[Music]
hair makeup wardrobe set design
they all go such a long way to telling
the story and certainly help
us as actors getting into the mindset
there's something about walking onto a
set and
nothing being what we recognize in our
world today
we get to be like fully submersed in the
experience of what these guys would have
felt beginning this new journey and
building this thing
you don't have to create in your mind
like what was it like to be in 1961
inside of the space i mean here we are
our incredible production design team
has gone to a ton of effort to
research archives so you go back and you
find one
picture in history and then you know
you're trying to figure out how to build
it what's the purpose of it
our nasa technician who's one of our
technical advisors
when he first came into this room he
kind of gasped and said oh my god it
feels like i'm back when these men were
you know some of the things were very
challenging but i think we pulled it off
the space suits are dead-on replicas of
the nasa
space suits patrick adams and i we got
to actually try ours on together
and i'll never forget that moment
because it was two kids on christmas
morning when you slide that thing onto
your body and especially when you put
that helmet onto your head and it clips
in
you're a kid again the wonderful ann
roth once said that
two people enter a fitting room and
three people leave
and that's the aim all of these folks
were
so game to wear things that were
different to go outside their comfort
level
and i think that's made a huge visual
difference
in the show all of the wardrobe and all
the sets
even the cars that they put in the
background just to drive through the
back of a shot you look at any place
that we're shooting at the right angle
and it really is this 1950s throwback
sandbox that we're all getting to play
in
there's been a lot of care and craft as
i think you can tell into making
this world feel as authentic as possible